jakl richard gotainer
[Musique]
ça fait et les doigts c'est plus vrai
que ce cas sa salle à l'autre
c'est sympa et ça vaut l'ascendant
et ça paie
à
hahaha
ok
et
à
sympa tout le monde en a parlé à
retrouver richard gotainer chez lui à
paris dès le matin il est derrière son
ordinateur pour gérer son site internet
lui je veux dire
bon p'tit déj machin tout ça je lance
l'ordi
pour avoir les messages les mails les
trucs très important j'écoute les
messages si en ahl message téléphone je
traite les choses par ordre de priorité
on va dire parce que je fait un peu tout
tout seul quand même un jeu léché
l'heure de la découverte des messages
postés des adresses les adresses email
et quand sa mère est une réponse je
réponds alors par exemple celui là et je
n'ai pas mis pourquoi alors c'est le
blues le blues de santa cruz de toulouse
ou de mulhouse en attendant je pécho
monde où l'on alors c'est sympa alors
j'ai regardé jusqu'au bout je suis
absolument pas concernée donc si le mail
qui veut une fenêtre pour afficher ses
trucs mal à en l'occurrence ce sera pas
ici quoi mais je trouve ça sympa des
petits belges ça faisait longtemps qu on
vous attendait en belgique mais si vous
êtes nerfs et puis ça y est la nouvelle
est tombée
vous serez chez doux le 20 novembre et
des petits belges
bon bah ça râle met ça et puis on va
faire une petite vérifie toujours au
foot tu es toujours vérifier tout laisse
trop là les bons ressorts élèves là les
petits belges jeunesse les fautes
d'orthographes ginès et ce salon est
authentique quoi autre activité qui le
passionne les photos de famille j'adore
la photo mais je crois que ce que je
préfère en photo cd photos mises en
scène à lamanon je vais vous présenter
ma famille
voilà par exemple ça c'est un truc qu'on
a fait ils sont un peu dingo les
gotainer on est bête surtout moi
d'ailleurs
voilà un déguisement c'est ça peut
partir de rien on se met un chapeau qui
se tient à dakar poubelles sacs en
plastique
ah voilà
en fait je ne sais pas je prêtais voir
dans la glace ça peut faire ça peut
faire ça il est important pour richard
de se nourrir donc direction la cuisine
alors qu'est ce qu'on va se faire comme
boîte
normalement pour les gens bien élevés
ces 125 grammes mais sommes nous on est
un peu
donc on va se mettre 150 l'interprète de
primitif est un as des fourneaux
j'ai monde allume gaz qui est mort ce
québec la châtre agréable au gaz avec
mon briquet coup je me brûle les poils
de la main et ça sent le cochon brûlé
charest veut ma chemise parce que on a
une longue histoire
eux c'est la guerre entre moi et la
sauce tomate
voilà je ne sais pas comment se
débrouillent la sauce tomate je peux
vous mettre un tablier je peux mettre
n'importe quoi la sauce tomate pas
toujours où ça vous en met partout mais
bon je veux bien qu'on en met partout
sauf sur ma chemise voilà donc gens là
je passe en seconde
voilà passe en second le petit la marche
arrière et la voilà à faut pas déconner
les patins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dray un peu de la peinture meilleure
santé
[Musique]
bon appétit richard et merci pour nous
s'il tombe pas ça à l'heure de la sieste
direction le studio où richard prépare
un nouvel album
je vais un peu les yeux fermés je
croyais vitry sur seine et à studio qui
s'appelle studio au codm allons répéter
avec les musiciens
[Musique]
mais l'enregistrement ne saurait
commencé sans une pluie de désinfectant
pas la csu pense près voilà on va faire
ça à petits coups mais ça pue poche je
te le pas round reynders personne d'un
turini
m
rires
c'était menu
m
la tuile
la première fois jouer du monde
j'habille et ses musiciens que
pense-t-il de lui là richard gotainer
le pire c'est vrai caractère de cochon
et en plus j'ai dragueur mais ça ça me
concerne pas tous deux comédiens
il est 13 heures grand séducteur j'ai un
peu casse pieds par moments de bien
durables et c'est un plaisir de
travailler avec dans le paysage de la
chanson française n'est pas deux gars
comme vos nerfs ça c'est sûr il est
unique car lors de pauses toutes les
demi heures
ça suffit et oui la recette de la
longévité de yuki les sucres lents du
midi ils vont lui permettre de répéter
tout le monde
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
richard gotainer
bonsoir salut bienvenue dans tout le
monde en a parlé
richard vous êtes né le 30 mars 1948 à
paris dans le 12ème arrondissement
vous arrivez avec un jour de retard et
comme à l'époque le tube ses ouvres la
porte richard vos parents vous prénomme
richard va tout simplement
voilà à quoi ça tient alors votre nom de
famille c'est gotainer donc ce qu'ils
ont ils dit je veux dire dieu unique
ouais bah appelez-moi richard quand même
un ouais c'est pas grave alors vos
grands parents paternels sont arrivés de
pologne et vos parents étaient
commerçants il avait un magasin de
meubles au faubourg saint-antoine
oui ils vous grandissez j'ai pas
beaucoup connu ma maman avec mon papa à
ils ont divorcé xavier quel âge je crois
que je dois arts 18 mois quelque chose
comme ça ou même avant j'ai pas le gpad
images de ensemble alors ce n'est qu'à
quatre ans que vous découvrez les
lunettes et le monde extérieur
à commencer par les dessins sur les
rideaux du salon mon père aurait dû s'en
douter parce que c'est ma dit
j'ai uniquement transmissible mon oncle
était comme ça mon père était comme ça
ils ont dérobé des carreaux c'était des
glaçons avec des fils de fer il aurait
dû se douter du sérieux qu ils ne sont
pas douter et à quatre ans comme je
pleurais quand on montrait vous savez
comme on montre aux enfants un avion une
vache
moi je pleurais parce que je voyais pas
le truc donc ils se sont inquiétés en
fait finalement j'étais quand même très
très très mûrs ou alors enfance j'ai
déjà très créatif à un touche à tout
comme ça ou trafiqué des photos et quand
vous avez eu votre maillot phone à l'âge
de 13 ans vous avez commencé à
bidouiller des sons de magnéto a été
pour moi une vraie création
c'est à dire que tout seul dans la
chambre j'enregistre à des trucs avant
leur jeu genre sein des fausses pubs le
défaut émission enfin bouger je faisais
du montage avec des bouts de scotch avec
des lames de rasoir est tout simple et
en fait finalement ça m'a
j'ai été à l'école du magnéto avant même
de sa marque je voudrais appeler assure
alors partir en colonie de vacances
à l'époque c'est là que vous rencontrez
jacky jacubowicz le jacky de du club
dorothée
vous devenez inséparables tous les deux
vous monter des petits spectacles
en fait on avait officiellement le rôle
de faire rigoler nos camarades alors on
déconnait évidemment le soir dans les
chambrées 1
il y avait une fois par semaine un
spectacle c'était le samedi après-midi
ou faisaient pas remonté sur les
planches en faisaient les égouts tôt
alors à l'époque quand on vous demande
ce que vous voulez faire quand vous
serez grand tous les deux vous dit on
voudrait faire poiret serrault comme
l'acier voilà un mage ou lettres michel
serrault absolument oui il paraît aussi
un peu à ma main voilà donc après un bac
philo vous entrez à sa 168 alors il y
avait trois mille étudiants il ya eu
trois redoublants cette année là
pourriez vous étiez parmi les triches
était de 268 a enfin à le faire mais je
suis vraiment nu ça m'intéresse pas noir
mais vous avez passez tout votre temps
sur les barricades ou quoi pas vraiment
non
non j'étais une ou deux fois la sorbonne
écouter le mend dit ça m'a gonflé grassi
j'ai trouvé que c'était pas bien
gt gt évidemment comme tous les mecs de
cette époque là j'étais j'avais envie
ouais un truc est ce que j'entendais
c'était un discours très coûteux très
très
tu avais rien à voir avec ma réalité en
fait un droit
ouais et donc ça m'a pas intéressé et
très vite quand même alors pour payer
vos études à l'époque on fait plein de
petits boulots vous êtes vendeur de
journaux marchand de légumes
chauffeur-livreur enquêteurs des
marcheurs
celui qui m'a qui a un qui sait vraiment
un signe là ma vie ces enquêteurs parce
que ça a été le premier boulot qui m'a
mis un peu le pied à l'étrier de la pub
et par là que je suis venu à la pilule
en fait c'est à dire qu'en faisant des
enquêtes dans la rue comme j'étais
sérieux
ben les mets qui me donnait confier les
enquêtes il ment confiait d'autres il me
donnait des analyses à faire il me
faisait suivre des stages de non
directifs donc déjà on rentre dans une
attendent un peu un peu nobles de la
façon d'aborder le marketing déjà là
mais à l'époque
vous êtes très attirés déjà parlé fripé
par le déguisement un jour vous venez en
cours avec une veste de docteur acheté
au carreau du temple
ouais il y avait des fripiers et frère
je pars' mais c'est vraiment un film
c'était s'étaient tous les trois avec
des haies avec une blouse grise
l'autre il avait un truc juifs voiliers
petits bonnets machin c'est lattakia
chapeau et tout ce qui compte et les
délits dont ils comptaient les sous il
avait des accents à couper dans le
couteau il était vraiment fort médaille
il recevait des balles énorme de
chemises américaine de veste d'un père
anglais tous adv achats & alors je
faisais un peu de trafic quand même
acheter des trucs je revendais un peu au
lycée et puis moi je ma vie est là-bas
et un jour j'ai acheté c'était à
l'époque de sergent peppers
qu'est ce que je vois gevrey une veste
dompteur rouge avec les brandebourg est
donc je suis rentré à la maison avec sa
mère c'est plus tu retournes j'ai
racheté un truc j'ai échangé contre un
truc contre une chemise qui était verte
jaune et marron
j'étais encore pire que la veste à
brandebourgs détient influencé par les
beatles à l'époque je suis très fier
parce que j'étais fan avant que le mot
fan des beatles existe
j'étais dans les premiers des love me do
when j'étais déjà sur le coup moi au
moment où ils vont nous faisons là on a
un dossier de l'agoa bah oui normal
ouais voyage initiatique obligé ouais
enfin bon j'ai jamais trop raconté cette
histoire mais en fait j'ai été aussi
faire un petit sauvetage de camarades
qui étaient un peu en perdit sur la
barre donc j'étais un peu cherché par le
ghana qui arrive tu vas revenir
il arrivait perdez sens bien ouais donc
j'ai été chercher et cet ep c'est pas
plus mal
donc comme il faut bien rassurer les
parents vous revenez assas et c'est là
qu'un copain vous propose le devenir
professeur de pub et pour préparer vos
cours vous achetez la publicité au
service de l'entreprise par un certain
monsieur robert roberge quoi
et là en fait vous découvrez la pub quoi
vous devenez concepteur rédacteur dans
une agence américaine
je me suis renseigné pour savoir comment
on fait pour entrer dans la pub m'a dit
faut un dossier j'ai fait un dossier
mais j'avais jamais rien fait donc là
dossier je n'avais pas donc je me
présentais en disant c'est un food aussi
parce que je me doutais bien qu'il
allait le voir
donc j'ai fait une trentaine d' agences
comme ça où j'ai été deux
directeur de création directeur de
création et chacun me donnait un petit
bout de la solution jamais aucun m'a dit
qu'il faut faire comme ça faut être
comme si il faut faire la demande au
bout de 12 de la 30e agence j'ai fait un
petit peu la synthèse de tout ce qu'on
m'avait raconté j'ai foutu
la plupart de mon dossier à la poubelle
j'en ai refait un et huit jours après
j'étais engagé à la dgi walter thompson
est une énorme agence qui était la
première du monde à l'époque grosse
agence s'agirait les civières très carré
sur le marketing exactement ce qui ne me
convenait pas mais en fait qui m'a donné
une formation très militaire notre sens
marketing du dernier est alors comment
vous êtes passés au au jingle et au bond
originale de le spot de pub
bah ça s'est fait un peu naturellement
salaire que déjà au départ maman m'ont
aussi aidé en montre aussi que je
présentais pour aller me faire voyager
dans les agences
j'avais déjà des sons que ne
présentaient pas les autres et quand je
rentrais dans l' agence la nuit quand on
filait un boulot qu'en tirera un sujet
qui traînait dans l' agence jeu
j'appelais des copains qui étaient des
pas des professionnels des amateurs et
je faisais je proposais un jingle je
propose à une chanson publicitaires
évidemment ça marchait pas c'est pas
comme ça que ça fonctionne alors comme
ça fonctionnait pas bien sûr fenêtre
jenson et voilà donc là vous avez monté
quatre caisses votre boîte de prod vous
produisez des jingle et des bandes
originales de spots de pub
alors il ya quand même ce qui s'est fait
de mieux en france depuis 40 ans il ya
bang à l'appel des champs il ya
infinitif ya saupiquet
et à vittel il ya des nets ya choco bn
vous devenez le maître incontesté du
genre le dieu unique du genre le gotha
nerfs des gens c'est vrai que c'était
des wagonnets en est et nord tu es très
créatif au jingle de pub ont été vendus
en cd et les gens ils ont acheté
continue dans la baignoire alors c'est
donc pendant ces enregistrements de pub
qu'en 76 vous rencontrez que d'angel qui
était guitariste de magma aidé par son
frère lma vous sortez tout un tas de
chansons qui ont été des tubes et lambda
primitif qui était inspiré d'infiniti
fmea chipie le sens pas trois vieux papy
le mambo du décalco le youki cette
histoire de couple en fait c'est à ça on
a réussi un truc formidable c'est un peu
comme mon amour c'est coup de bol un peu
intégral c'est-à-dire de trouver la
complémentarité
l'auteur et le compositeur c'est un
couple très très difficile à composer
parce que d'abord il faut pas d'ego il
faut savoir dire c'est pas bien c'est
fait sans que l'autre sexe et il savoir
le recevoir aussi en disant t'es sur qui
est sûr de ça parce que c est en même
temps et échanger aussi les qualités
donc l'apothéose c'est mars 83 à
l'olympia en vedette chose est alors
vous êtes célèbre c'est arrivé vite vous
pensez c'est curieux parce que moi j'ai
depuis je suis tout petit j'ai toujours
la passion elle a été un peu peut-être
way we en colo chili c'est tout
et d'un seul coup d'être célèbre il n'y
avait pas y avait pas une
grande différence non se pressaient pas
du jour à la nuit vous et tu es un peu
plus à l'est quelles ont été les
réactions de votre entourage quand j'ai
vu c'était quand même célébrité
médiatique
mon père il m'avait lâcher la grappe le
jour où j'ai été le voir et je dis papa
je veux faire de la pub
oui parce que lui il voulait que je sois
avocat docteur ingénieur enfin bon je
sais que voilà comme il a vu
certainement dans mes yeux que je jeu ça
y est je savais ce que je voulais faire
il m'a laissé faire et quand évidemment
j'ai eu l'art de connaissances des gens
du public
ça a été pour lui je pense à une
réussite il savait que son fils avait
réussi et autres mamans ça lui
permettait d'avoir des rendez vous plus
facilement chez préfère ça s'est bien
passé avec les médias à l'époque c'est
non seulement ça s'est bien passé avec
les médias mais je pense être à sa
technique je dois ma ma notoriété jeu le
jeu refait le parcours maintenant à
l'heure actuelle vu l'attitude des
médias
la vie d artiste je suis pas sûr de
pouvoir arriver à la même notoriété je
gagne de l'argent
ah bah oui oui oui et en amour ça vous a
aidé cette notoriété avec les filles je
peux je sais pas ce qu'on appelle à un
grand tombeur les grossesses sont très
très vite intéressé évidemment mais je
déjà je ramène un peu ado je ramais un
peu fait que je cavale derrière crâne et
puis du jour où la notoriété est arrivé
ça peut changer la face des choses c'est
beaucoup plus facile et juge en est
je n'ai plus qu'à me servir voix quel a
été le meilleur moment de cette époque
ce serait plutôt une espèce d'ambiance
très créative c'est ça que je je c'est à
dire à une espèce de ces rendez vous
avec claude angèle avec celle marange
est quand on rencontrait d après mme
idrac qu' on était ensemble et comptait
connaît autour d'un d'une pub pour ya à
faire un truc ça c'est ouais c'est un
c'est un truc que j'ai beaucoup aimé et
le pire moment c'est le lin succès du
rendez vous au tas de sable
rendez-vous au tas de sable c'est votre
premier long métrage vous avez travaillé
cinq ans vous êtes scénariste
compositeur acteur et c'est un flop
total flop on se prend une veste non
première phase et injurieux c'est on est
traité comme
du pus ouais enfin bon cela dit quelques
années après moi j'ai reçu des courriers
j'ai reçu des mails mais en insistant
mais dans la crainte est ce qu'on peut
voir ce film aux cassettes il était
épuisé tout à fait j'ai rééditer ce film
est que depuis c'est un film culte est
un truc
alors aujourd'hui vous faites toujours
des spectacles c'est un peu vous dites
comme à la maison quoi c'est des potes
autour d'un feu de bois et vous vous
sentez vos chansons qui sont qui sont
éternels en fait il fait avec une bande
de jeunes mecs qui se régalent qui
certains connaissent tout harker mieux
que moi donc si on s'amuse des serveurs
cela compense en êtes nostalgique de
l'époque disons l'époque du show zazou
l'olympia aux nostalgiques pas du tout
non il vous est rancunier est-ce que
vous en voulez à des gens finalement non
je ne mangeais pas de jets pas de rang
calanques nom et j'étais jeune j'ai
appris une chose
je crois qu'il est très importante c'est
que la rancune la haine et tout ça tient
trop de place dans une vie dans un coeur
dans une âme pour pouvoir lui accorder
de l'importance
il faut très vite dégagé ça de manière à
laisser la place à des choses plus plus
plus y est plus orienté de ça si c'était
à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez
pas pareil dans les cinq ans qui ont
précédé la sortie du rendez-vous et à de
simples en fait j'ai tellement j'étais
un peu fâcheux j'ai tellement cru as a
way que je n'ai fait que ça à d'accord
et en fait j'ai un peu mis tous mes
lâcher la proie pour l'ombre confédéral
et donc je pense que là j'en serais plus
âgée serait surtout de trucs en même
temps continuer à faire des disques oui
le jeu vous allez disparaître
qu'est ce que vous voudriez qu'on écrive
comme épitaphe sur votre tombe je ferai
peut-être en deux temps oui il y aurait
marqué game over est bien en dessous un
simple ailleurs shotgun faire c'est cher
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux